welcome to Destiny's children a weekly
let's play series in which hunter Dave
Titan Tom and warlock Lucy grind smack
shoe and loot their way across the solar
system as sorry excuses for guardians in
this week's episode we gear up ready to
take on the nightfall strike the
inverted spire to the left cannon left
cannon landed on jump through some
literal hoops so the game not only made
us jump through figurative hoops before
we now have to and Lucy visits the salt
mines might have got a bit salty salt
was all over here listen okay I was
having a bad day
right so after jumping through some
hoops right it's strike today yeah we've
all week we've been jumping through some
hoops too we can strike that prepared
it's gonna be worth it
yep it's gonna be especially worth it if
we get the cool racking gun yeah I think
we should do a single straight
run-through of the strike first and then
those are good
well do the Rat King we need five
minutes left on the timer but we won't
worry about that too much right now and
thank God the Royal wrap right up
whips going we've come a long way since
episode one maybe maybe a car does boost
there because there's a lot of hostiles
here apparently Wow we do just defeat
the hostiles oh wait hang on I realize
so this is the one we did beat beta Wow
another beta well I never played that
fat strike in the beta Peter sir so fade
cool we can't skip this if we die I mean
if we do a rat King run ten minutes
remain you're miles away Tom so thank
you you'll be upright time everyone to
you
yeah you're gonna you know you're doing
something you've apparently been reading
up so your guys that a guide us through
and tell us all much beeps urgently
that's good for you baby I'm dead I just
got absolutely moved yeah here is
Guardian now how everyone I just hit 230
power level and what is this recommended
level
that's only ten what's ten power levels
doing friends I'm very disorientated I
have no idea where I am where am I
supposed to be going Dave where are you
I'm fine fine this oh okay like I'm fine
I'm fine
there we go
[Music]
that may take a planet here we go
can you stop playing with the dregs
access cornflakes jump in my car
Oh No I've took the shortcut so
basically the reason they are taking the
mick out of my jumping is because at
home I'm playing as a hunter and I got
very used to the hunters jump those
hunters jump and then warlocks jump is
so so different and I just really
couldn't get the hang of it and doing
some the platforming sections I might
have got a bit salty I wish that was my
source all over here get sniped by a
scion pick me up coach I'm still good oh
my god move okay so it looks like we can
if when we're doing all right King run
we can skip this fit yeah because it
just has pressed forward so it'll be
tricky but well I've got the smoke bomb
that makes us invisible so we can just
invisible through stuff he's gonna be
very useful I might have accidentally
clever
scions certainly but that's [ __ ] a
real thing in 2017 isn't it Wow Buchan
you got to either booty like groceries
wait who's down I know I think I think
they're not Klan oh joy now at games
what clan it's real fun I think I think
there's people in the audience who
happen to be doing what where are you no
I won't do that who did you guys block
me off in you think so no I think you
just got me is the worst jump as he as I
landed so I landed it very safely
hopefully you'll respawn next to us yeah
I'm just traversing deeper I know I mean
deeper daddy no traverse deeper baby
sharifa Lucy please ring disability is
that means I have diarrhea diarrhea
moderate has been applied to my
character ring discharge at the Sunport
we stopped saying my discharge because
as a woman it's very much as those rings
are the rings well I caught ya come here
the rings are on my screen right now are
the ones I make this invisible so we can
get Sam improve or increase our time
right they'll go off when you shoot okay
all after just a little bit oh I felt so
there you go Coby it's a grenade
it's grenade going you seen anything
that highlights what alignment we're
supposed to have on our weapons on all
the Rings disappear off for a while
those the Rings that give you time but
yeah oh yeah okay we keep that mind for
next is there anything that shows what
it just has promotes deeper so do we
need to go these guys know we can plan
one pass but well we'll know that for
next time
yeah got bearings first oh I fell oh no
I'm so low I just fell love berries
yeah up the barrier oh oh it's down you
can see your home oh no are you also
farmers yet oh hello
we have this boy is goodbye forever love
starting far away it's change my the gun
it does nothing
even on a goblin which gun Auto AB that
see you're telling me there was
something to do with like the colours of
stuff yep I'm not sure how I know so if
he's got a purple shield yeah we do that
though
but isn't it wasn't like an additional
layer to it buddy oh this submachine gun
is sent a mass for these guys I can't
keep it on any any form of mass all
right me can you relax please
I'll give me that sweet sweet mo thank
you yeah let me change out to like a
Auto right so is it just because speed
is such a big deal for this strike is
the shield thing just just to make that
a little bit quicker or as in the color
code thing yeah it's just those those
enemies are difficult to just slip by
existed yeah it keeps saying things like
void energy surrounds you
who's it saying that to but just at the
bottom oh is that that you get a damage
boost for it or something cuz I heard
someone talking about if like yeah yeah
yeah if it's void energy surrounds it
you get damage boost to your void
weapons yeah so that's oh thank you
three minutes well awk energy flashes
before you that apply to everyone
yeah so the strategy that is most
there's people just on your body yeah
it's fine so actually that most people
are using is having each volt a year
each person on the fire team with this
again each person on the fire team
having one of the weapons
and then switching up that person one
person is the fire boy one person calmly
primary DPS when when the message pops
up Sofia Soler whoever's got the total
weapon then becomes that I understand
smart oh shoot me I'm not actually
applied that yeah so we can void energy
surrounds you so he's got a void weapon
I mean like it might not be useful now
but I'm on solar my avoid check yeah
I've got a decent void or a rifle maybe
should carry that when we do the
wrecking a temple okay so we can
probably the problem with skipping is
just have run past a lot of enemies and
they almost zone I mean I have pretty
high level energy weapons for everything
so I can kind of just for the gap like
if neither of you have any void weapons
I can use this you need to just spring
to the deep side at this point oh this
is tricky
I mean why sprint
when you can fly one minute remains
okay this way fly you fools it's there
seem like another area that we could
just zoom through in a sparrow so those
are the rings you gotta jump through
yeah so the game not only made us jump
through figurative hoops before we now
have to please okay ah you both down
yeah yeah I'm back now so there's two
main character and snow my sneeze Oh
what are they I've heard anyone want to
say those words smell of like weirdly
like fell over so there's two main
enemies that when you kill her well
their names
do we just fail time yeah we're just
three seconds are right in two seconds
around mission failed
okay okay well I don't think you're us
oh that's right all right we have to
defeat Oh fellow void energy whose voice
again me sorry y'all prime me any oh my
god
I have made my way to themselves oh my
god sometimes it's art oh god it's a
just that random dude over there I think
you must be the clown's guys my void
weapon is a [ __ ] handgun
see I know I've got my power weapons
avoid so I just took out an enemy hog
that's me you know oh okay
access the conflicts I'm gonna try for
the hoops as well
the rhiness all right got the cornflakes
okay this is the jumps yeah I never
scared
Iona Fred no ghost I'm afraid no god
damn jumps I should be afraid I should
carry on going yeah
give me the hoops Kimber the hoops
I shouldn't have done the second jump I
was fine gooshie if you wait for me
there I could probably just it miss yeah
let's see how the invisible tragedy
works
oh we have to go have to get kind of
close just don't honk you know how long
you're lost
oops not incredibly long but Lucy James
hello behave yourself
I got you everyone get together
so have you used it before presumably
right do they disengage the moment you
use it pretty much let's go so let's get
to this corner over here in this for
trying get right in over there you ready
stop stop stop go to father ever get
together yeah where is it we're gonna go
through the hoop yes boy Yi's valid
strategy confirmed let's go let's go
okay press forward so this is presumably
a skip point as well
solar that's me that's you I've got
quite the cooldown on a Mayan visitor by
the way you know just FYI I can't summon
a sparrow
traverse deeper alright those rings here
we need to hit those [ __ ] Wow
the problem is it's got absolutely
worked so grenade when you're going into
that ring you gave up it's not giving me
the option give it a few seconds so I'm
gonna how we can get those around me
jump I can do I got a couple of them
need help with his blood guard since her
in there oh man I need some help there
you go I get that ring bark energy come
on up again after the new murked oh yeah
this is troublesome
stop that discuss the behavior I can try
for the revive but probably nothing
blinking soul energy just standing still
ouch you guys up yeah oh Jesus agent
Weiss wife on my show you a belly to me
boy yellow okay anyone else low on ammo
oh yeah I have that one supercharged
pressed forward so we can do a skipper
they're all they're all malla enemies
good it's not as up top yeah those
Cylons are gonna pain but keep on
jumping Oh Dave spirals Oh let's go
solar energy oh my god I thought I'd
like exploded you okay you just keep
going yeah there's a couple of rings on
the way but it's not worth getting off
this barrel to find Oh
I jumped it oh no my robot eliminated
rings out here oh I'll go nope don't
come back you know we try and figure out
where those two captains are there in
each room right okay remember yeah
oh okay yeah those are them I can I can
spam my all into this window somebody
how bout me how come we're so close are
you in the left all right all right
dead I'm gonna go in there as well and
spam mine okay
let me know when you're going in I'm
going somebody going through the window
as much as I'd hope please
if it revived me with my oh wow okay so
with you look at all that [ __ ] I can't
even get my pass at my spiral past them
because they just destroy it time I need
her with this legionary oh your head
alrighty
oh my god what's attacking me
there's blood guards in here he's like
okay push him over okay now what the
other side's twice it's this guy
the Colossus yeah yo man just oh I get
it I gonna like said cool game I can res
you okay okay you got em no no no that
both of us where is the scholar he's
right there he's where I just threw my
grenade oh there's a couple of them
outside I think he just died he just sat
on my setting my dogs right board the
drill for the drill let's go let's go go
there oh there's folks down here do we
have to fight these guys
I bought the quadrille probably not oh
I'm on the right I'm gonna pull the door
right
oh no there's some Latin here hot lads
in here
five minutes we got this it would have
failed the UH
wrecking that I can't unless is anymore
rings go down right maybe go down in it
I did do this mission
yeah Wow
glad ya la da da
give me the bat Wendy yes they've got a
cool-down yeah res has a cool-down
okay my boy is holding up okay I'm eight
seconds times five repel attackers okay
so we have to fight here I think it's
just until the trends yep trying to so
many resets oh my god oh my god I hit
the jump on just four I landed and we're
not great
yeah but where do we go from here low
there's a big personal cannon die I'm
gonna start on the environments I'm
through but like I can't get anyone I
was flying for there and he just came to
a hard stop and then felt if I if I
activate like the next crack or
checkpoint would it bring you back okay
just go in
thank God yeah you just need to cross I
am well where is everyone
kill me get up there
dad
okay I'm still not back out full house
I'm gonna save you a seat
no I'm not no don't I'm gonna go two
seconds left Wow what was that
Oh Angry Men there it's like they build
their enemies to be just as annoying as
possible I'll get clear the drill okay
clear the drill
oh no the Rings oh yeah now I remember
this great wit what's that kick that was
my shoulder charge increase it kick oh
my god this is bad news don't mind me
guys
just possum for rock energy oh I'm on a
sparrow and I might not want to be where
do I go yes you made it don't know where
you are but you've made it oh my god I
gotta play the drill well we respawn on
you we should right I don't know maybe
we've got pushed forward as far as I can
I'm not sure we're supposed to go oh so
far away
sparrows rats do not work
oh no it's fine it's fine like joining
allies oh did it did it work yeah you
know if you get far enough
okay you can bear that in mind I'm
waiting there are there we go through
these harpies we don't we don't actually
have to just go down
nope you're down nope there's something
across on this side that we have no idea
that's getting it what do you want
we've got four years it'd be nice to get
this right yeah cuz their pricks gonna
load in there all right we're just gonna
kill him in a few seconds he you gotta
keep an eye on the ground because he
does some weird place [ __ ]
hey all your stuff and if that hits you
it will I don't think it's not a next
phase there's money this impending I
mean we go seconds I appreciate it
don't lie to me like this they're like
my guns doing like no damage feels I'm
just connect for now Sola I'm so doing
I mean we got to the we got to the boss
that time okay we've got nine kills
that's how that's how much of that has
been dead I'm gonna drop at my feet now
ready ready they've seen us there so
okay
should be enough to actually climb all
right okay it's going well
this is the first time we've got this
far whoa no we got this far but it's the
fastest record as well remember try and
stick together and don't push ahead I
know the rings look delicious but stick
together use the shield stuff because
that's what slow rings are in elite
biscuit cross there's only one except
over this get over there captain captain
digestive is what I'd call you all right
I'm gonna go for the what I need help to
kill an asylum
I've got a long range where's the Scion
on the right and then I'm gonna if you
go if you guys push left I'll support
you from the top and grab these rings
I'll go through the ring you I fell
again this planet loves berries kill
that guard anything too annoying
we ready the shields down on get the
centering cuz his shields down
oh oh okay he's owned Centurions own son
turns down
yeah golems are you guys supporting fire
alright okay seven six five four three
two one
razmik the respawn has a planet remember
me I'll be you have a dollar some solar
okay many shields I need to come down
I'm really low so I'm thinking I'm
thinking just let me know when it's done
it's it's changed hasn't changed
she'll just down oh it's down yeah yeah
one of them one they mean okay Boyd Boyd
that grenade was Perth oh my god okay
one of them sound okay go push okay we
just effects we need to kill the
Legionnaires can stay there okay all
right get get rings if you can don't
take any unnecessary time to the right
if you say yeah we're gonna go for the
right bunker I've got my ultimate so I
can just plop that in and hopefully
it'll reach me yeah um I want to
recreate fun some minutes now this is
podracing oh god don't get flashbacks
[Music]
alright get the ones off the top we need
to kill this ion up top and get the make
them up does everyone does it everyone
have grenades ready avoid mg/l oh jesus
H Christ right I need to ice blue over
there
oh he just said avoid I'm gonna go Alton
there okay go go now
nice you don't okay I'm gonna find get
one of these rings it's probably a bad
idea
I go go low go low yeah cuz they go down
the flat ground ignore that big dude if
you can job me to go in YC go go in an
old enough for a grenade in there go in
the core nice out okay all right to the
left cannon left cannon drop pod landed
on what we do really I really wanted oh
no I shouldn't put my heel down let's
just left it all right yeah laugh of me
that happened just in front of me as
well I'm gonna try and activate the the
drill yeah oh great show great show
great oh boy energy here he goes time to
get here my drill is being activated I'm
definitely gonna die but okay just wait
in here until it gets to 100%
yeah nice and then we just like again do
take time I'm horrible down that yeah 93
for seven yes yes yes yes yes don't go
right
okay so this thing I hate the thing
again Bungie please if you get along
with canon make sure it just goes
directly into where he needs to be it
goes into the wall which gives it go
alright I'm gonna stand at the top of
the hole if you can get a ring before I
jump in get the Rings as soon as you can
as oh why is it keep launching me above
it oh my god go on okay okay we're gonna
have like two minutes I'm dead you're
about to be warps to me okay cool I'm
about to be deadly the reason flaps
nothing yep
joining allies okay I'm dead okay
successful got a lot of times kill this
boss it takes way more than two minutes
yeah she's like four different three the
famous phases all right solar energy
blinkin as much as I can I'm a I'm a
energy weapon
she was kinetic if you're not on yeah no
secret rings surprising us he's purple
revelation okay I'm out of well
everything pretty much I'm Minnie me one
minute remaining
these harpies here but you know i yeah
it's also not smashing
oh hi friends while he's standing mind
telling me sir maybe just played enough
my grenade in his feet 10 seconds would
record that was the closest we've calmed
fission mailed so we didn't manage to
complete the strike but we came close
right anyway thanks for watching episode
2 of Destiny's children we hope you're
enjoying the series and look forward to
reading your potentially scathing
comments about some of our destiny
abilities if you want some more destiny
2 content guides and live streams that
make sure you subscribe and feel free to
tell us what you want to see in the
comments or by hitting us up on Twitter
stay safe Guardians